what's the secret to being an actor's
director hmm that's like the biggest
compliment uh I could ever get is I love
when people say that uh
the secret is I think kind of everything
we've been talking about it's creating a
space where actors feel comfortable
and safe to play and do their work and
find new moments and try different
things
um
and realizing that like everything is
about as a director you're creating the
atmosphere on the set so it's you know
creating an atmosphere that feels
creative where people feel like they can
try things
um
yeah that's what I would say is the key
to being an actress director
what if it's an outdoor scene yeah and
you know you have permits and everything
you're allowed to be there but you just
know what are those
you just know you're working against
elements yeah and how much Freedom are
you giving someone in those moments
yeah I mean
what you're trying to do ideally is to
keep all the stress
sort of away from the actors so you know
you have people whispering in your ear
like yeah we have uh 20 minutes to get
this scene done and we have six more
setups and you know but you don't want
the actors to know that you know so it's
like you're constantly trying to Shield
them from all the stress of a movie set
so that they can feel creative and like
they can have the time to try things
so it's almost like you're a parent and
yes there is a Santa Claus Virginia yeah
you don't want you don't want them to
know the you're shielding them giving
them a safe bubble I mean sometimes yeah
I mean sometimes it's also good to say
like look we have about
four takes of this so just to let you
know you know because otherwise they
might be
in rehearsal mode for the first two
takes you know so I think it's just
again finding that balance between
uh letting them know what's going on but
not letting them feel like the stress of
the movie Set because sets are stressful
you say you trust your actors yeah
what if there's one you don't totally
trust
um how do you build it
yeah I mean
again it's all casting it's like but I'm
trying to think of an example I I really
have been lucky with the actors that
I've gotten to work with but but there
are certain things that you
realize about actors that you know
because I like to do a lot of
improvisation
um and I remember on my second feature
uh Gabby Hoffman who's a wonderful
actress came in for like a week or I
forget maybe a few days even
and you know we had been improvising a
lot and and I told her like oh yeah just
improvise and she's like what I and she
didn't she was resistant to that and
didn't want to do that so I think
there's there's times when certain
actors especially if they haven't been
with the production the whole time they
come in and they have a different way of
working and I think you have to be open
and sensitive to that and find a way to
incorporate everyone in and make them
feel like they're part of the company
but at the same time get what you need
from from each actor yeah
can trust be turned on or does it really
take time to manifest or sometimes it's
just not it's like chemistry it's either
there or it's not yeah I think it has to
be built I think it has to develop and
like hopefully through the casting
process and the rehearsal process that
you're building that trust the whole
time and then by the time you're
shooting
you have
a trust with the act because if there's
no trust between the actor and the
director like you're in trouble
um you're not gonna because they're just
gonna be resistant and pushing back and
that's not a creative atmosphere and
you're not going to get a good movie
even if a scene calls for tension
well that's different that's different
and that's than you then you're playing
a certain scene and there's tension in
this scene but that's different from not
trusting your director yeah
how do you help an actor that does not
like to watch themselves
don't let them see the monitor
I mean there are certain actors who
fight to see it
um
but yeah those actors that don't want to
watch themselves they don't have to they
don't have to see the dailies they don't
have to you know you just
kind of work with them almost like
you're doing theater
and you work with them on the character
and on their what they're what they're
playing in the scene but yeah they don't
have to look at the monitor
shouldn't an actor want to see
themselves eventually
to give themselves feedback yeah I mean
I think in this day and age now
especially with young actors with all
the self tapes that they have to do and
I mean I find it very helpful
I think what you have to do is you
almost have to like disconnect from oh I
hate the way my face looks in that and
just look at it constructively and make
it about the work
I remember when I acted in Fairhaven my
first feature and we were editing I had
to like just start to call myself by the
character name and just disconnect from
it so I wasn't like getting too
self-conscious and just be like well
what's the beat of the scene need to be
and
um so yes I think it is very helpful to
be able to watch yourself but I think
you can't make an actor do that
um
but hopefully you know they can
disconnect enough and see themselves
constructively and and learn from it
that's interesting so you're almost like
it's almost like it's not Tom that was
someone else right there well I had to
learn that too I kind of because that
was my first time in an editing room and
uh I just had to because for the first
few days I was just I couldn't even look
at myself
um
so yeah I just had to eventually just be
like well I have to edit this movie so I
have to get this done
um so you just kind of Disconnect and
make it about that's that's a character
in the movie and I'm gonna you know make
this the best I can
how do you help two actors work together
who don't have chemistry with one
another oh God
um
I would I mean I would never cast to
people that didn't have chemistry that
would be terrible but but yeah in class
situations
um
just by being open to the other person
and working with them and not uh doing
it some prepared way that you did in
your bathroom mirror like work with the
other actor
um
because I think chemistry is just being
open
to the to the other person and taking
what they're giving you
um
and that might be nothing
and then there's got to be a response to
that
um
so yeah that's difficult though for sure
why because uh maybe there is a tension
that's yeah not said and then you pull
both actors aside separately have the
other one going back and then you say
you know
Tom what's what's going on here like how
come you're in the scene with this
person it's
how do you really I mean are you do ever
ask someone like how do you see this
person or how do you feel about them and
maybe then they can develop more for
that character yeah I mean I haven't had
that situation I think that's
tough I try to let them have their own
Dynamic and not get too manipulative and
too involved and you know there's
I watched the Criterion commentary and
they they needed like a baby to cry on
the cue and they like pinched the baby
you know it's like it's like you hear
those like horrible stories about
manipulative directors so
um I try not to do that stuff uh but
yeah I think I think letting actors find
it and giving little
a little assist where you can and you
know but not being too micromanaging and
controlling